the earliest humans didn't have words
for colors they had words for objects
and actions and it took tens of
thousands of years for those words to
evolve into the names of the colors we
used today looking back gives us a
glimpse at how those early people saw
the world around them we'll also answer
that age-old question which came first
orange the fruit or orange the color I'm
Dr Erica brazovsky and this is other
words
[Music]
other words
a human eye can perceive millions of
slight gradations of color but unless
you're a designer or an artist you
probably only regularly use about 10 or
so color words and they are remarkably
similar across all cultures a landmark
study by Brent Berlin and Paul K found
that people across the world developed
their words for colors and more or less
the same chronological order for example
if a language only had two words for
colors they were always black and white
if a language had only three color words
they were black white and red yellow and
green came next in either order then
blue brown and so on this hierarchy
closely matches human psychology after
all what could be more visually
fundamental than the dichotomy between
light and darkness and were hardwired to
have a strong emotional reaction to red
as it has a lot of survival significance
from food to sex to violence blue is
surprisingly far down the list
considering it's most people's favorite
color but actually due to a chemical
cork blue is very rare in nature except
of course for the sky but you don't
really need a word to help identify the
sky which Sky do you mean all the Blue
Sky the English word white can be traced
all the way back to the
proto-indo-european root quite which
meant to shine black similarly goes back
to the pie blag which meant to burn a
reference to the color of what's left
after burning red is unique in that it's
the only color that has a pie root that
just meant the same thing red although
it may have been used to describe
anything that had a warm or interesting
color yellow came from the pie gal which
also meant to shine and gave us many
related words like gold glimmer glow and
gleam green comes from the pie grip
which meant to grow for its obvious
connection to plants and also gave us
Grays and grass interestingly even
though humans can perceive more shades
of green than any other color we just
use one word for them all think about it
how many different kinds of red can you
name compared to different kinds of
green the reason is probably that even
though our ancestors were surrounded by
green or rather because they were
surrounded by Green it's just not that
interesting to us a 2016 study by Hannah
J Haney and Claire Bowen found that
humans across many different languages
have an easier time communicating warm
colors than cool colors this color wheel
for instance has twice as many common
color words on the warm side than the
cool side to understand why just picture
with a world may have looked like to her
early ancestors which things in their
field of view are worth talking about
the cool colored ones or the warm
colored ones perhaps for this reason the
word blue has been traced back to the
pie root ble which meant yellow
there simply wasn't a need to describe
the color blue until much later on when
humans started making dyes and paints
from rare materials like lapis lazuli
orange was pretty late to the scene the
old English term for the color between
yellow and red was Jay laraid which
literally meant yellow red but then
sometime around the 15th or 16th century
Portuguese Merchants began importing an
exotic fruit to Europe known by its
Sanskrit name Naranja this came to be
naranha in Spanish
in Italian and orange in French the
latter two likely dropped the N at the
beginning through a confusion about
where the article ended it's the same
way we got an apron from a naperin and a
nickname from an eek name over the next
couple hundred years people went from
saying things were orange colored or the
color of an orange to just saying they
were orange so there you have it the
fruit came first but we're still living
with the effects of not having a proper
name for for the color for a long time
it's why this is called a redhead and
this a red robin even though they're
both clearly the color of an orange
brown comes from the p-i-e bear which
meant bright possibly in the sense of
polished wood indeed it also gives us
the word burnished the animal that we
today call a bear went by a totally
different word prior to the Middle Ages
but since it was considered dangerous to
even mention the Fearsome Beast by name
Ancient Hunters came up with a euphemism
Barrow which meant brown one they were
so superstitious in fact that the true
Old English word for bear is now lost to
history purple is one of the few common
color words without a pie root it comes
from the Latin papura which referred to
a certain shellfish that was ground down
to make a distinctly colored dye because
of its Vibrance and Rarity purple became
very popular with the wealthy and
powerful and is still associated with
royalty today it wasn't really until
humans became proficient artists that we
started adding colors to our vocabulary
by the hundreds most are either based on
the source of the pigment like stones
plants and insects or to what the color
reminds us of whether it's the sky the
birds or a beverage so how many unique
color names are there it's hard to say
but it's definitely in the hundreds if
not thousands some have long histories
dating back to the beginning of
civilization and some were made up
recently by crayon marketing departments
you may not need more than 10 or so on a
day-to-day basis but the explosion of
words shows that color has gone from
something that we just used to survive
to an integral part of expressing
ourselves and making our imaginations a
reality
[Music]
a what
what could be more visually fundamental
than that then the dichotomy considering
it's most people's favorite color
[Music]